Julie pante était sur notre plateau pour
donner sa version des fait dans
l'affaire cohé jeudi dernier aujourd'hui
nous avons des nouvelles de de Sébastien
l'animateur a porté plainte pour
tentative d'extorsion de fond et
dénonciation calomnieuse petit rap et on
en parle avec myiam
palombarass depuis plus d'un mois
l'animateur Sébastien cé est visé par
les témoignages de plusieurs femmes
l'une d'elles a même porté plainte pour
viol contre lui il a détruit ma famille
il m'a détruit moi aussi mais alors que
l'homme qui a été écarté de l'antenne de
énergie ni depuis le début les
accusations dont il fait l'objet j'ai
les preuves de mon innocence je me
battrai contre cette lamentable
entreprise de déstabilisation ces
avocats viennent de faire savoir à
travers un communiqué qu'une plainte
notamment pour dénonciation calomnieuse
et tentative d'extorsion de fond en
bande organisée a été
déposée alors bonsoir myiam Miriam ça a
été ce weekend super qu'est-ce que fait
quelqu'un de très rasseral le
weekend mais elle fait quoi non mais tu
cherches des rasserat tu à la recherche
de rass ouais je fais que ça regarde
Twitter et' quel la panade je dis ça va
êre bien ok très bien ma chérie dis-moi
tout oui alors qu'est-ce que tu fais là
alors ce soir on a on a énormément de de
dossiers r ouais c'est vrai tu m'as
écrit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure ouais
ouais ouais c'était c'est assez énorme
donc on commence par cé commence par qui
tu veux me fais pas chier d'accord alors
alors on dit que la défense la meilleure
défense c'est l'attaque donc calme-toi
démarre pas comme ça tout le temps tu es
insupportable
arrête de donner ton av c'est pas
méchant c'était écrit ça c'est pas
méchant don c'est pas méchant la
première chose qu'il fait donc là il va
après avoir porté plainte pour mais j'ai
rien fait non j'ai rien fait après avoir
après avoir portter conis pour
harcèlement et et dénonciation calomieux
ces avocats ont ont lancé un comment
s'appelle un communiqué de presse
aujourd'hui où ilattaque pour dire
qu'ils attaquent aujourd'hui ils ont
déposé plainte pour tentative
d'extorsion de fond en bande organisé
dénonciation calomnieuse faux et usage
personne contre personne non dénommé tu
comprends ce que tu dis
ou force qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait g s'il te plaît Monsieur B c'est
une contre-attaque très vive sur le plan
judiciaire parce que ça veut dire qu'ils
estiment que les accusations contre
Sébastien cohet encore une fois je donne
leur version sont
orchestrés tentative d'extorsion en
bande organisé euh en gros avec un but
financier il parl de calomnie orchestré
c'està-dire qu'ils estiment que derrière
cette plainte se cacherait j'emploie des
mots prudents évidemment se cacherait
une tentative de plusieurs personnes
pour extorquer de l'argent à Sébastien
cet cette démarche judiciaire soulligne
la gravité de la situation et répond à
la calomnie orchestrée pour gravement
porter atteinte à l'honneur et à la
réputation de notre client avec un but
financier dissimulé c'est ça que je
voulais que vous lisiez depuis tout à
l'heure donc je vais le faire
moi-même ou je
fa avec des pr tu as raison tu as raison
chérie avec des preuves avec des preuves
matérielles pertinentes dis style
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont apporter les
preuves de ce qu'ils dénoncent sur le
front judiciaire voilà reste maintenant
à avoir l'autre partie et évidemment le
camp adverse Cyril mais c'est une très
vive contre-attaque judiciaire et puis
aussi ce qui est important c'est que
comme il y a eu des SMS qui ont été
dévoilés sur Twitter et que ces SMS pour
eux n'ont pas été identifiés pour pour
la pour l'équipe de coé l'équipe
d'avocat de coé ce sont des des
mensonges ce sont des faux SMS et c'est
justement ça qu'ils vont essayer
d'apporter comme preuve aujourd'hui
d'accord d'autres choses oui oui non sur
C c'est ah sur coé on attend il est
toujours pas revenu sur énergie non
toujours pas euh toujours pas il y a
l'enquête interne qui est qui est
toujours en cours sur sur la radio et
puis puis la jeune femme a déposé ses
deux plaintes le 18 et 20 novembre pour
viol sur mineur de de de plus de 15 ans
et viol pour des faits qui remontent à
l'année dernière très bien oui sur la
partie extorsion de fonds et but
financier on a eu accès à des des
preuves et des témoignages qui montrent
que la jeune femme a fait appel à des
conseil ce qui est normal des avocats en
demandant combien elle pourrait retirer
financièrement à coé donc c'est la
théorie de la défense de ce qui dit
qu'il y aurait un but financier avant
même l'idée de de avant même l'ffet il y
aura un but financier voilà ça appuie
ces propos là très bien merci en tout
cas de de de cette petite info alors on
a le test de culture générale des Miss
France tiens qui vient d'arriver tiens
je je vais vous le faire un petit peu
vous êtes chez vous pour voir si vous
pourriez être Miss France vous aussi qui
n même mon père qui attend son
jogging par exle il y a des questions
donc c'est quel pays a intégré la zone
euro cette année la Croatie le
montenénégro l'Ukraine quoi c'est vrai
dans quel pays se déroulera la prochaine
Coupe du monde de rugby Afrique du Sud
Australie Argentine Australie austral
bien sûr euh bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr je pourrais pas être Miss
France donc l'anné 2024 est synonyme de
jeux olympiques quelle Miss France sera
l'ambassadrice du relais de la flme
olympique au côté de Thomas Pesquet
Jamel Debou et Thierry Marx iris mener
marine lorfelin ou Amandine petit
marineorel marine l'orphelin exactement
euh voilà donc c'est c'est c'est chiant
euhésa pas c'est chiant quelle est la
capitale du Brésil tiens Brasilia Rio de
janiro Brasilia bien sûr quel pays
appton le pays du soleil le vent la
Corée du Sud la Chine ou Japon ou vos
gueules
euh quelle cérémonie récompense le monde
de la musique aux États-Unis les Golden
Glob les
BAFTA gramyard exactement quel artiste
est l'auteur de cette célèbre affiche du
Moulin Rouge Picasso Toulouse are
touous vous don la réponse avant que
vous con la Goul ah non vous don la
réponse avant pas on va pas y arriver ah
ouais voilà donc voilà donc c'est ça
donc il y a plein de questions ah
question tiens parmi ces propositions
lequel de ces animaux tuent le plus
d'hommes chaque année l'hippopotame le
requin le lion
hippopotou c'est fou c'est fou c'est
fou c'est fou c'est fou c'est fou c'est
fou euh une autre question tiens euh ah
pas mal cette question tiens un
croissant et une chouquette coûte 200
2,10 € au total le croissant coûte 2 €
de plus que la chouquette combien coûte
la Chouet il nous prennent pour des cons
10 10 non non
non05 + 05 font010 c'est surtout que ça
existe pas fait exprès vous êtes
débil des chouettes je vous me défie de
ramener une chouette à 5 centimes
exactement moi aussi c'est 30 C ti
Nathan et Tom ont à de 64 ans ouais que
Nathan est trois fois plus âgé que Tom
quel est l'âge de Tom oh même 64 peux
même pas réfléchir
16 16 ans ouais il a 16 ans il a 16 ans
ce h là euh
c'est pas il y a plein de questions
comme ça c'est pas mal du tout votre
médecin vous prcrit un caché à prendre
toutes les demi-heur combien de temps
vous fra-t-il pour prendre six cachés
les dem 2h de 2h de ouais cach 2 va
prendre tes cachets nous fais pas
chier tiens parce que j'ai l'abitude de
prendre des cachets c'est pour ça que je
le sais ah merci
c'est vraiment sympa de faire l'émission
avec
toi ah dans le code de la route est-il
autorisé de téléphoner au volant muni
d'une orillette oui non non non voilà
donc c'était les questions de de Miss
France ce test est donc noté sur 40
points les Miss ont également le droit à
une dicté et l'examen est donc noté sur
60 points sachez que le classement
numéro sont deux égalités il y a Miss
Roussillon etise Aquilina et Agathe
toulieu Miss Limousin ils ont 40 40 sur
60 et celle qui a mieux réussi le truc
c'est V Miss Alsace vous savez pourquoi
elle a dictés bien parce qu' en fait
elles ont souvent assigné les livres
d'or dans province et donc il fa qu'
fasse pas trop de d'orographe gros
bisous c'est pas dur
àc j'ai passé une excellente journée une
bonne
émission tiens l'animateur Stéphane Bern
était l'invité de samedi dans quelle
époque il en a profité pour revenir sur
son homosexualité plus particulièrement
sur l'homophobie dont il est victime
depuis toujours regardez nous en parler
après Patricia avec vos parents ça été
difficile avec votre mère notamment vous
dites elle préférait me voir mort plutôt
qu'homosexuel un jour elle m'a dit je
préfère te savoir mort qu'homosexuel je
lui dis bah ça va être difficile j'ai
vécu des trucs vous n'imaginez pas vous
n'imaginez pas ce qu'on peut vivre on en
dit des bêtises avz pardonné oui je
pardonne j'ai j'ai tout pardonné à mes
parents non alors ouais c'est assez
c'était assez émouvant de de de
l'entendre alors c'était pas la première
fois he qu'il parlait de son
homosexualité puisqu'il a fait son
coming out en 2 9 dans dans le magazine
Têtu il est est parti très jeune de chez
ses parents il est parti très très jeune
de chez ses parents à 17 ans B ben
justement parce que parce que sa mère
n'acceptait pas son homosexualité comme
il l'a dit elle préférait le voir mort
plutôt comomo donc il a décidé de de de
de quitter de quitter sa famille et puis
et puis en même temps il le voit il a
réussi à leur pardonner c'est ça qui est
assez assez fort il il explique he on on
on est souvent très aimant vers ses
bourreaux on aime toujours aussi ses
bourreaux dit-il il monte et en fait
comme lui il vient d'une d'une famille
très bourgeoise il reconnaît quand même
qu' grâce à eux il a une très bonne
éducation et que et que finalement
malgré tout bah il est il est toujours
enfin toujours en lien avec eux très
bien il est avec son compagnon depuis
combien de temps Stéphan alors ça fait
plus de 2 ans c'est un c'est un jeune
alors c'estan bayeres voilà c'est ça
c'est pas le fondateur du club de
rencontre le cercle de Socrate si si si
donc c'est c'est un cercle un peu up où
en fait des 'agit d'un club privé haut
de gamme permettant au célibataires gay
de faire des rencontres amoureuses c'est
ça c'est ça une parti cl reverse 10% de
ses bénéfices àassociation le refuge qui
vient en
aess ils ont officialisé leur relation
2021 oui merci c'est sympa que tu
viennes Dansel en fait cétait au cours
de la de la la Marche des fiertés qu'ils
l'ont officialisé ils avaient fait un
post sur Instagram et puis quelques mois
plus tard ils sont allés sur par image
faire une très belle série photo et
c'était c'était super parce que c'était
la première fois qu'un qu'un couple
homosexuel était en Coupe de Paris Match
bravo bravo donc c un belle il y avait
aussi Karine Le Marchand tiens elle a
affirmé une nouvelle fois son soutien à
Stéphane plazin on va en parler dans un
instant de Stéphan Paz tu peux récupérer
tes petites fiches là euh ce dernier
étant accusé de violence conjugale des
faits qu'il conteste bien entendu on
regarde et on en parle ensemble regardez
partir sans vous poser une question sur
Stéphane Plaza accusé de violence et de
menace par trois ex-compagnes vous vous
continuez à le soutenir publiquement
c'est mon ami il y a une justice c'est
important que la justice aille plus vite
pour ce genre d'affair pour les femmes
qui ont subit des des maltraitances et
c'est important que la justice aille
plus vite pour les personnes qui
estiment qu'elles sont accusées à tort
c'est toujours votre meilleure ami il
fait partie de mes meilleurs amis oui
oui alors oui c'est c'est c'était une
belle déclaration surtout que elle
l'avait déjà plus ou moins défendu dans
Paris Match hein où où elle avait dit
qu'il avait été victime de enfin
effectivement qu'il avait eu une grosse
altercation avec la fameuse jade que ça
avait été violent mais qu'en aucun cas
il était un homme violent d'ailleurs
elle avait dit à la limite c'est un con
un gouja mais je l'ai jamais vu violent
rarement en colère donc en fait voilà
elle prend à nouveau sa défense faut
quand même savoir que Karine larchand
c'est une très très grande amie de
Stéphane Plaza elle a toujours été là
pour lui à la mort de sa mère en 2016
quand il a eu des problèmes d'alcool
elle a également été là il parta en
vacances régulièrement ensemble et c'est
vrai que l'enquête avance ou pas alors
l'enquête pour l'instant elle est un peu
en standby alors il y a il y a eu deux
plaintes pour pour violence sur conjoint
qui ont été déposés Stéphane Plazza
lui-même pe porter plainte pour
harcèlement il y a trois plaintes de
femmes qui ont été contactées par les
victimes présumées qui ont également
porté plainte pour l'instant Stéphane
Plaza n'a pas été convoqué par la police
donc c'est toujours en suspens pour
l'instant ça avance assez lentement
quand même très bien donc lentement
alors il y a Laurent rquier aussi
quiavait défendu hein Laurent je prends
toujours ce ce genre de chose avec
beaucoup de pincettes on a vu des tas
d'affaires du même genre qui ont été
contredites ensuite par les intéressés
ou elle-même il faut laisser Stéphane
tranquille pour qu'il puisse se défendre
de ses accusations je n'ai aucun doute
sur sa probité oui il y a aussi Sophie
verjani qui a pris celle qui anime avec
lui des émissions qui a pris sa défense
et qui et qui s'en prend même assez de
façon assez assez assez violente aux
femmes en disant regardons ces femmes
qui se sont liguées contre Stéphane pour
faire plus de buzz avoir plus de
visibilité et en tirer certainement
quelques profit donc donc voilà c'est il
a plein de copines qui le défendent je
et euh et toujours M6 bien sûr qui
défend toujours Stéphan plazin ver dévit
pas de sa ligne pour le moment il reste
à
l'antenne fidélité à Stéphan Plaza et
c'est vrai que la plainte qui a été
déposée contre les plaignantes si je
puis dire enfin est une sorte de
contrefeu qui sert Stéphan Plaza parce
que ça pourrait pourrait non pas
discréditer mais atténuer la portée des
victimes des présumé victimes on va
parler de Gard pard dans un instant mais
juste avant ce weekend c'était
l'Eurovision Junior et c'est une jeune
française qui a gagné elle s'appelle Zoé
closure elle a 13 ans on regarde sa
prestation mon cœur B en ryme il palpite
si vite quand je chante pour
toi non cœur B
r non que va
TR pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
[Musique]
je chante pour
[Applaudissements]
toi c'était pas mal he mal après il y a
une histoire là je sais pas quoi de je
sais pas c'est contre le harcèlement
ouais ouais mais il y a un bail chelou
je crois on va en parler demain je crois
je je sais plus quand là ouais ouais il
y a une journaliste qui m'a appelé qui
m'a vous êtes davantage au oui B c'est
heureusement tout sur l'Eurovision
Junior on est très fort ça fait ou leion
junior pe gagner c'est rien organiser
c'est pas comm comm l' on AAG de la
victoire de zo bravo bravo Zoé
[Applaudissements]
regarder je hy
contp
[Applaudissements]
on va
l'équiper afin qu'elle puisse n faire
revivre ce moment avec l'ensemble de ses
compatriotes qui avait gagné qui avait
gagné l'an
dernier deux fois suiteag c'est fou ça
il y a Gabriel qui qui a félicité zo je
crois qu' était je sais pas où il
était il était là ouais tu as raison et
ben voilà B c'est comme ça
elle a gagné devant l'Espagne et
l'Arménie voilà bon on arrive à
remporter l'Eurovision Junior ça sert à
[Rires]
quoiir c'est sympathique sympa c'est GAM
qui chante voilà ok
très c'est du divertissement quand
j'auris une question intéressante je
sais que je peux me tourner vers vous je
sa que vous êtes toujours là pour
vraiment pour m'éiguiller